what's going on people today we're about
to break down episode 21 of Attack on
Titan season 4 in which Aaron Begins the
rumbling and the true origin of the nine
Titans was finally revealed in this
video I'll be explaining everything you
need to know including the hidden
details about emir's life and the real
reason why she chose to help Aaron
destroy the world before we dive into it
I know that some of you watching might
be new to the channel so if you want to
see breakdowns like this every week then
be sure to smash that sub button and
drop a like if you like the video
okay so in the last episode Zeke tried
to convince his brother to join him in
the euthanization plan by taking them
into grisha's memories he hoped this
would make Aaron realize that he'd been
manipulated by their dad but as it turns
out their dad was one being manipulated
by Aaron the whole time thanks to the
secret ability of the attack Titan Aaron
was able to send Christian memories from
the future and these future memories
convinced their dad to murder the royal
family in this new episode things
continue directly on from this with
Grisha transforming into a shifter and
giving Freda a beat down not to mention
squishing the Rices with his bare hands
following that we eventually returned to
the main area of the past Dimension
where the oldest eager brother is still
trying to process what just happened
based on everything he just saw Zeke
realizes that their dad only did what he
did because he was shown specific
memories from the future that Aaron had
chosen to send back this manipulation is
why Grisha ate the founder despite
knowing he would never be able to use
his power and it's why he entrusted
everything to his son leading us to
where we are now I explain this next
part in my last video but just in case
you didn't see that Aaron goes on to
confirm that four years ago when he
kissed his story his hand he saw the
same memories his dad saw in the rice
Chapel among other things it's implied
that this included memories of the
rumbling which was sent to their dad by
a version of Aaron even further in the
future as a result for the last four
years he's known this destruction was
destined to happen and ever since he
went to Mali he's been doing the
necessary things to arrive at this end
point
in this scene however Zeke decides to
try and take back control of the
situation as he orders him here to
sterilize every Elden in the world
because she's a slave to the Royal
bloodline yamir begins to follow his
command without a second thought and
she'll be able to actually do it when
she reaches the coordinate Zeke then
correctly points out that although Aaron
might have seen glimpses of the future
he obviously hasn't seen everything and
this is proven by the fact that at
various moments along the way he didn't
know certain things would go against him
anyway azimir edges nearer to the
coordinate Aaron desperately tries to
bait free from the chains around each of
his wrists these chains are pretty much
unbreakable considering they were made
by the founder herself but he knows that
if he doesn't escape now then the alien
race doesn't have a future that's
exactly why he was so desperate to reach
her and after struggling for a while he
pulls away with so much force that both
of his thumbs were ripped off
after the opening the anime then
suddenly flashes back around 10 years
earlier to a moment between Frida and
Historia as we already know Freda would
sometimes visit Historia during her
childhood and was the person that taught
her how to read and write and in this
particular clip they were reading about
a character who was based on yamir Fritz
we can tell from the devil on the left
page that this book isn't yumiya's real
backstory but instead it's one of the
many fairy tales inspired by her over
the centuries Kruger said back in season
3 that anyone can become a God or a
devil as long as people believe it and
in emir's case she was considered a God
by the alien Empire while also being
viewed as a pawn of the Devil by the
malians as we're about to see the truth
was a lot more complicated than that
because for a start she was just a
regular girl who lived peacefully in
this Village around 2000 years ago the
anime briefly shows her going about her
daily life getting water from the well
but unfortunately this was the day her
Village was invaded by a violent tribe
and as the eldians these aliens
proceeded to burn everything to the
ground and kill many of the locals
including this woman who was implied to
be yamir's relative she was then
captured as a slave alongside anyone
else who wasn't killed and they all had
their tongues cut out to stop them from
speaking hence why later on they only
communicate using hand gestures
one small detail is that yamir continued
the habit of not speaking even after she
gained Titan Powers which is interesting
because you know with these shifter
abilities her tongue definitely would
have grown back at this early stage in
the timeline though she was still just a
regular person and every day the slaves
were forced to carry out basic tasks
like carrying water or looking after the
pigs if we pause for a second on this
screenshot you'll notice that yamir was
fascinated by this Aldean couple who
were getting married since the love
these two had for each other was
something that you may have wanted for
herself in a similar way to how Aaron
was Yearning For Freedom or how Zeke was
yearning for fatherly affection what
yamir wanted was to be loved hence why
she always did things to try and please
other people this ties into what Frida
said about how the girl in the book was
the kind person who helped others but in
reality this desire to help others is
what screwed up yamir's life more than
it already was on one specific occasion
a slave allowed a pig to escape and the
king of the aliens wanted to find the
person responsible he threatened to
gouge out an eye from every single one
of them unless someone confessed and it
didn't take long for them to all point
the finger at yumir while it's not
specified whether she really did it or
not her options were still pretty
Limited in the situation and by
accepting responsibility it meant less
people would suffer
following her confession the king
declared that she was free to go as she
was sent into the forest while these
alien soldiers hunted her for fun with
yamir continuing to lose blood this
honestly should have been the end but as
she continued to stumble forward her
blood spilled on this flower in Attack
on Titan this type of flowers become a
symbol for being reborn since every time
it appears someone gets a second chance
at life the first time we saw it was
when Zeke was on the brink of death only
to be given a brand new body the second
time we saw it was here just before a
wounded Emir gains the power of the
Titans and the third time we see it is
later on when after death her spirit is
reborn in the past dimension
anyhow in this sequence she looks up to
see this unbelievable tree towering
above all the others and she walks into
it because she was still trying to find
a place to hide on the inside she then
steps down into a body of water and as
she begins to drown this mysterious
creature appears out of nowhere in the
last season Kruger referred to this
creature as the source of all living
matter but whatever it is its design is
inspired by the hallucinogenia for some
unknown reason this version of the
creature had the ability to titanize
things hence why the tree that lived in
was so large and by latching onto
yumiya's spine it turned her into the
first ever founding Titan when it comes
to size her shifter easily surpasses the
colossal and every other Titan until
this episode and its design was
definitely more bony compared to what
we're used to seeing in the past we've
seen that spinal fluid is so important
when it comes to passing down shifter
abilities or creating the time
transformation serum and now we know
it's because the power of the Titans
itself literally originates from this
spinal connection
moving on with her new shifter abilities
you'd think someone in emir's position
would want to get revenge on the alien
tribe and stamp them all to pieces but
instead she returned to serve under the
king as baffling as this seems it does
make sense for her character since her
Titan Powers made her useful to him
which in turn brought her closer to the
love she was desperate to receive this
scene takes place many years after she
first became a Titan and by then he'd
been using her in various ways to expand
the tribe resulting in them now being a
lot richer although it should be obvious
to everyone that he never actually loved
Emir from her point of view this was the
closest thing she was gonna get and in
her own messed up way she did love the
king
her undying loyalty is why he was more
than happy to give her three children
over the years and these kids were
called Mario Rosen Cena if those names
sound familiar it's because nearly 2 000
years later the 145th alien king decided
to name the three Wars on parodies after
them
while we're on the topic of names in
this episode the first LDN King refers
to himself as Fritz which is the true
name of the Royal bloodline that existed
this day although the name was changed
to Rice when they arrived on parodies
the fact remains that all real-blooded
individuals are members of the fritz
family and it's because of their
connection to him that yamir obeys those
with Royal Blood we'll talk more about
the topic of blood in a second but first
we got a few clips of the original
founding title on the battlefield as she
was about to wipe out a wave of Malian
soldiers back in these days enemy
Nations had nothing that could possibly
fight back against the Titan and because
of that ymia's presence made the eldian
Empire quite literally unbeatable thanks
to her they were able to easily defeat
Mali and presumably any other Nation
they wanted to enabling Fritz to keep
evolving their empire in terms of
Manpower and infrastructure
by this time 13 years had now passed
since she first gained the power of the
Titans and despite all the different
ways Fritz had used and abused her she
still didn't love him in a Twisted way
on one occasion as the King was
addressing his soldiers at least one of
his men had been plotting to assassinate
him since someone had buried the spear
in the ground beforehand due to that
this Soldier was able to whip it out
before anyone could stop him and he
threw it hard enough to instantly kill
the king or at least it would have
killed him if yumiya didn't make herself
a human shield although her injury
through the heart was really bad we have
still seen shifters come back from worse
but injuries like this only heal if the
person has the will to live as we can
see here yamir's will to live vanish
when she looked up at King Fritz because
in this moment he basically told her to
get over it and get back to work until
he said that her eyes were actually open
but after hearing his final orders
that's when she no longer had the will
to carry on as she closed her eyes this
flower from before flickers on screen
and in a cruel twist of fate her spirit
is then reborn in the past dimension in
this new reality yamir took on the same
appearance she had when she was a young
slave and as a slave she would fulfill
British final orders for the next two
Millennia whenever one of her
descendants would call in the power of
the Titans Emir would personally be in
this Dimension molding each shifter by
hand it's important to remember that
time also passes differently in pause so
although these shifters always look like
they're being created straight away in
reality it must have felt like months or
even years every single time she had to
make one back in the real world King
Fritz had her dead body chopped up for
their daughters to eat in a scene that
was foreshadowed all the way back in the
end credits for season 2. at this time
in history no shifter had ever been
passed from one person to another so the
King was basically trying anything he
could to make sure yumi's power didn't
disappear no matter how disgusting it
might be as the only humans with the
emir's blood in their veins Mario
rosencina were the only ones capable of
inheriting the shifter abilities and by
eating their mother's spine ymias Titan
was divided between the three of them
this is different to the present day
where normally one person eats one
shifter but because he meets daughters
at her spine together while in their
human form this is apparently the secret
to dividing Titan Powers gradually the
three Titans that the daughters possess
grew into the nimino today and in this
shot we've got a brief look at some of
the first iterations of these Titans to
exist
during the king's dying speech to his
daughters he made it pretty clear that
he didn't want this age of the Titans to
end which by extension means that yamir
would never be free her strange love for
him kept her Bound To The Past dimension
for nearly two thousand years and in all
that time she never tried defying him
until Aaron arrived as he catches up
with her he reminds him here that she
doesn't need to serve anyone and that
she's just a person who's essentially
lost her true self that's why he lets
her know that it's her choice what to do
next she can either continue to stay
here and work like she always has or she
can help him destroy the world that
always treated her so badly ultimately
she does decide to go with Aaron instead
of Zeke making this the first time she'd
ever disobeyed someone of real blood and
if he pause for a second I'm gonna
explain why Point number one is that
Zeke basically thought of him here in
the same way King Fritz did in that he
thought of her as a slave lacking free
will that he could use for his own
purposes even until the end he never
acknowledged her as a real human being
whereas from the start Aaron saw her as
a person and couldn't believe that she'd
been here alone this whole time he
understood that it must have been Agony
to be in this realm of being orders for
thousands of years and unlike Zeke he
tried to offer her a choice rather than
simply viewing her as a tool
Point number two is that yamir was
clearly waiting for someone to free her
from this pain because after serving
other people our whole life I guess she
had to be reminded that it was okay to
exercise her own free will from her
point of view lashing out of the world
is clearly more appealing than spending
another 100 years trapped in the past
Dimension which is what would inevitably
happen if she follows these
euthanization plan
now before we move on to the amazing
reveal of Aaron's founding Titan there
were a few bits of trivia that I thought
were worth mentioning to begin the name
of this episode is from you 2000 years
ago which is a reference to the first
episode of Attack on Titan which was
called To You 2000 years from now the
names of these titles make it sound like
you may have sent something to Aaron in
the first episode which he then received
in this episode and one interpretation
is that it's referring to the memories
of her life story which he likely
received when they made contact
alternatively it could be referring to
the power she gave him to start the
rumbling or it might simply be referring
to the fact that she's been waiting for
2 000 years for someone like him to
arrive
next up earlier in the episode 3D
mentioned a story that she should be a
lady-like person like the girl in the
book and this is what directly led to
her overly kind personality that we saw
in the first couple Seasons the girl in
the book was called Cresta which is the
same fake name that Historia used when
she joined the cadets and it wasn't
until she met a Titan shifter called
yumea that she gained the courage to act
as her true self
finally the last thing to point out is
that the concepts in this episode are
heavily derived from Norse mythology
whether it be the world tree Ragnarok
the nine Titans corresponding with the
nine Realms or the fact that yamir is
the name of the first Giant in both
universes the connection likely runs
even deeper than just this however my
understanding of Norse pathology is
limited to my unfinished playthrough of
God of War and the MCU for that reason I
really can't go into any more detail but
I'm sure there is someone out there who
knows all about this stuff
anyhow moving on to the rest of the
episode in the real world only a second
did pass since Gabby blew off Aaron's
head in this moment here the source of
all living matter jumps out of his spine
to connect with his brain granting him
the true power of the founding Titan
thanks to you Mia's blessing almost
immediately following this the first
thing he does is crumble all the
hardening on parodies collapsing the
walls that have been there for over a
century as some of the hardening falls
down in Gabby's Direction Aaron begins
his weird transformation which was
unusual for a few reasons not only is
his new Titan significantly larger and
more bony than any type in history but
it also takes on a similar shape to the
hallucinogenia its bizarre appearance is
the result of Aaron transforming while
in this condition because the source of
all living matter had no choice but to
improvise and make a new body based on
its own image if Aaron had made contact
with Zeke when his body was whole then I
can guarantee you this sent to be Titan
never would have happened but because of
what Gabby did this is now the
consequence
the Titans in the war then begin to
March which is what Armin always
predicted that Aaron would do although
what he wasn't expecting was the amount
of Titans that would be set free earlier
in the season the military was planning
to do a small rumbling using only the
Titans in Chicago so Armin couldn't
understand why the rest of the wars were
being crumbled as well his answer came
seconds later when Aaron used the
coordinate in one of the most epic waves
we've seen as he was able to send a
telepathy message to every single Elden
on the planet all of Yuma's subjects
were mentally taken to the Past
Dimension regardless of where they were
in the real world and the cameos include
Annie's dad Historia and all of the
Warriors
after introducing himself over the
speaker system Aaron pretty much spells
out why he wants to wipe out life
outside the walls and to summarize it
for this video his goal is to protect
the people of parody is by eliminating
all their enemies outside the island
from his point of view the outside was
hatred of eldia has grown over the years
and he realized that there was no
peaceful way of stopping this cycle of
hatred as long as there are aldians then
there were always going to be those
people who want to destroy them for
being devils and so in his mind putting
an end to everything is the only way to
save the people he cares about a large
part of his motivation during the time
skip was to make sure that Historia and
the rest of his friends didn't need to
inherit any shifters since he wanted all
of them to live long lives by stopping
the cycle of hatred he will accomplish
that goal but the obvious downside is
that billions of people have to die in
the process
the episode ends with this ugly black
and white shot of Aaron's head and this
is what he looks like on the inside of
this giant skull
anyway people that was my breakdown for
episode 21 of Attack on Titan season 4
and if it helped to understand the
episode in any way then I'd appreciate
if you hit that sub button and let me
know your thoughts in the comments
thanks for watching as always and until
the next one peace out